[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today all right
Brian's in Salt Lake City hey Brian how
are
you doing great Dave thank you for
taking my call sure what's up so
question I I've followed you for for
years um but uh I I am in a situation
where I'm starting to again um and it is
a little bit of a shame around student
loans so I'm 49 years old and I've got
about
$220,000 in student loans and I've been
paying for about 19 years what do you
mean by starting
again I have used your program um and
and had success but I
always counted myself as debt-free not
including my home and not including my
student LS so you used your program that
and said it was mine okay well yes okay
I I get motivated and then I don't and I
I try to just like ignore that this is
out there okay and and obviously you're
calling because that's not
working yeah I'm anxious about it and I
uh I'd love to know kind of what your
thoughts are I I know that there are
some programs out there around like
forgiveness if you've been paying for
what's your household income Brian I
make about $90,000 a year okay the
program is cut your lifestyle and pay
this off in 12 months that's the
program live on 70,000
minus taxes and pay this off in one year
that's about $1,800 a month and that
means you're not going out to eat and it
means you're not going on vacation and
it means you're not doing half the other
crap you've been doing with your
$90,000 and you're going to finally
address this headon that's the
program quit looking for a shortcut man
it's not work for you you're going to
have to hit it right straight in the
nose hit the bully in the nose
okay does that make
sense yes it does it's very doable you
got no other debt but this right in the
house I I I own my car oh okay so we
went back to that too okay so how much
what's how much do you owe on your car
about 15 okay that's not too bad all
right so 355,000 out of
90 so we're debt free in under 2 years
can we agree you could come up with
175 a year for two years
please please tell me you can do, 1500 a
month or you'll figure out a way to cut
everything but I mean that's what you
got to do it's you you you've been
trying to find a way to not do this and
it still go away and and the problem
with the whole thing is there's only
really one solution and it's it's its
name is not Joe Biden I mean there's
only one solution and it's name is Brian
uh cuz I'm not going to pay it off you
are Brian do you have any margin in your
budget at the end of the
month yeah how
much I I I haven't been good at
budgeting but I'm I'm not I wouldn't
consider myself living paycheck to
paycheck I have a little bit of savings
give me a round number a given month I
understand you Haven been disciplined
but what's a round number each month
that that you know you've got margin
on I'm not sure if I fully understand
your
question can you scrip together in your
mind right now a month to throw at this
yeah uh I could I could I could come up
with I think between $700 and $1,000 a
month okay all right and then when you
start doing your budget you're going to
get that to 1500 and you're going to be
done in under two
years and that doesn't include you going
out and making some extra money a guy
who makes 90,000 has got some skill set
this is about absolute you talked about
motivation I get motivated and then I
lose motivation and you know motivation
is is really about an end result it's
it's a it's a real clear focus on a
result that I want and then the actions
take place naturally that's what real
motivation is what's my motive for
getting up early or eating right or
saving money what's the motive and
that's the end result you've got to
start looking at the end result and no
anxiety over this debt anymore you
mentioned that uh all the other things
if you get clearly focused on that Dave
then the actions take care of themselves
here's the way I look at it sometimes
when I'm looking at this stuff if I'm
going cuz I do that to I do that too I
guess we all do we all do if someone
that I dearly loved one of my
grandchildren's life depended on
it could I well yeah absolutely yeah
that's a clear motive I mean you know
and so it's not a it's not a question of
could I it's a question of will I yeah
that's right that's what it comes down
to create your free every dollar budget
today the simplest way to budget for
your life